بدأ [موسيقى]
sänger منذ حوالي 60 عامًا في
1960 انطلاقا من طوكيو اليابان
وبدأنا بفكرة أساسية للغاية عن
الإيماءات الصغيرة التي يمكن أن تترك انطباعًا كبيرًا
في حياة الناس في عام 1975 ،
أطلقنا محفظة نقود معدنية تخلق إحساسًا حقيقيًا
حول
أصبح هذا هو العلامات المبكرة لأعمال الترخيص لدينا ،
لذا فهذه هي مكتبتنا
حيث يحدث كل السحر ، لذا حيث
نجلب كل شيء إلى الحياة ، اتجاهاتنا
قصصنا هي جميع منتجاتنا ، هذه
منطقة من المكتب نسميها المحور
تُعد مكانًا للتجمع الاجتماعي ، ولكننا
أيضًا نعقد اجتماعات أسبوعية هنا
للتأكد من أن الجميع على نفس
الصفحة
[موسيقى]
على عكس معظم شخصياتنا ، كانت هذه
الشخصية تركز على
عميل من جيل الألفية ونعتقد أن
هناك الكثير من الروابط مع المجتمع  هذا النوع
من اللامبالاة من الجيل الذي
يأخذه نوعًا ما من قبل شخص ما
[موسيقى] ،
وأحد أعضاء فريق العمل الجدد لدينا
هو مدرس جريت ، وهي
مدرسة تركز على الجيل Z  هذه
السيدة المكتبية المعتدلة السلوك في النهار
والليل تتخلص من كل إحباطاتها
في آلة الكاتاوكا
[موسيقى]